rated M for Mature  it's happening all over again they will  take everything from us I can't watch  that same fate before this family your  spirit must be like iron I'm glad I  found you my boy what are you doing here  I'm here to bring you home this is your  fight imagine your family who is this my  name is Mira Forrester I'm here to sell  our  and how does it just lines and nephew  get himself center for  I heard you want to be a ranger why I  want to protect house Forrester must  know what assets are worth taking  especially if you wish to have an  alliance with me  three thousand Betty don't what could  save my brother  if you're to save your house you'll need  more than the two of us at you sided an  army of cell swords and a man to leave